[Music]
the truth is
there's lots of really exciting
developments in
the climate space but it's about
scaling it all up at like
by a thousand times something that
only federal governments have
the resources to do
is the kind of system change it's all
there it's all ready
to go we just have lacked the political
will
to implement it that is significantly
because of psychological
factors and i think what the climate
emergency
movement is doing is intervening
in that realizing that our enemy
is not just fossil fuel companies
and their huge network and industrial
agriculture but also
denial denial and passivity
are also enemies no one
no one can say this system is working
that's margaret klein solomon
and this is the ritual podcast
the ritual podcast
hey everybody how you guys doing what's
happening i am rich roll
indeed this is my podcast good to be
here with you guys today
i don't think i'm going out on a limb
to suggest that for a litany
of unfortunate reasons our current
political system
seems hardwired to exacerbate
problems and rather inept at actually
solving them
whether it's our current civil rights
struggles or managing the pandemic
it can really leave one feeling
disheartened
then of course there is the dark beast
of climate change lingering in the
background
fomenting this sense of existential
dread because
as much as we would like to believe that
we are nearing
the edge of a cliff the truth is that
we've already
flung ourselves off that cliff this is
not a situation that requires we hit the
brakes
we need to put the engine in reverse
and i say this not to be
cynical not to over exaggerate or
be some kind of nihilist although i
think those would be normal responses
but
rather as an immediate call to action
and the action demanded by us
all of us requires that we
begin by reframing the situation placing
it in its proper
objective context today
margaret klein solomon phd is here to
guide us
a clinical psychologist turned climate
warrior margaret graduated from harvard
and received her phd in clinical
psychology from adelphi
university she is the founder and
executive director of the climate
mobilization
which is a volunteer organization
dedicated to catalyzing a worldwide
climate emergency
movement in addition margaret is the
author of
facing the climate emergency how to
transform yourself with climate truth
which
in addition to providing the structure
for today's conversation
is a really powerful emotional guide to
processing the climate emergency
alongside tools to help us all rise to
this great challenge got a bunch more i
want to say before we dig into this one
but first we're brought to you today by
daily harvest
because sometimes once in a while
you just need a little vacation from
cooking and the time consuming hassle of
healthy meal prep
with a robust line of healthy and
delicious food based on real fruits and
real vegetables things like
soups smoothies harvest bowls flatbreads
oats and lattes
daily harvest makes keeping my kitchen
stocked with go-to's farm frozen to lock
in peak nutrition and taste
the best part my daughters love them
especially the smoothies basically
it's just an awesome shortcut lifesaver
to getting kids eating better
more often and everything these guys
make is ready to enjoy in minutes their
latest delight
are scoops their new plant-based ice
cream they're delicious free of
additives preservatives and fillers and
are made only with whole nourishing
organic ingredients
i dug into the vanilla and salted black
sesame the other night which was
pretty divine i gotta tell you so here's
the deal eating clean food with daily
harvest is easy
it's effortless whether you're having a
night at home or need a quick bite on
the go
so keep it simple this summer with daily
harvest go to dailyharvest.com and enter
promo code rich roll
to get 25 off your first box that's
promo code rich roll for 25
off your first box at dailyharvest.com
that's dailyharvest.com we're also
brought to you today by seed
fun facts for you guys our bodies are
comprised of about
10 trillion cells but our microbiome
outnumbers human cells by a factor of 10
which is so
crazy the more you think about it we are
far more microorganism than human
and it's super important that we care
for our microbial cells and propagate
our healthy gut ecology
which is why i'm super excited to
partner with seed
seed is bringing much needed precision
and efficacy to the global probiotics
market with their flagship
product the daily symbiotic the daily
symbiotic combines 24 different
probiotic strains in one dose
and these are strains that naturally
occur in the human body
that you can't get from things like
yogurt or other fermented foods
these specific strains have been
clinically studied to deliver systemic
benefits
including digestive health skin health
heart health
and gut immune function if this world of
probiotics and microbes fascinates you i
would highly encourage you to listen to
my conversation with the seed founders
arakats and raja durr
that's episode 445. basically it's a
deep dive on all things microbiome but
you'll learn that
there's no other probiotic in the world
with this much clearly
referenced clinical work behind their
formulation not to mention
they have a keen focus on sustainability
in absolutely every facet of their
business model
they package your first shipment in a
glass jar and then monthly refills come
in a compostable pouch which is pretty
cool to learn more about the science
behind seed
head on over to seed.com rich roll
or use the code rich roll for 20 off
your first month
of the daily symbiotic that's seed
s-e-e-d
dot com rich roll or code rich role
at checkout and finally we're brought to
you today by theragon
i have to tell you guys the body
connection this is not fantasy
this is real when you are stressed when
things are hard
and you're not able to process it that
tension
shows up in your body in things like
aches and pains and it sucks it doesn't
matter
if you're an elite athlete or just a
regular person trying to get through the
day
muscle pain can greatly impact your
quality of life which i can attest to
the last
five or six weeks i've been trying to
finish this book and i've just been
sitting
way more often than i should be and i
got to tell you my lower back has been
duly letting me know but daily theragon
sessions have really
helped theragon is basically a handheld
percussive therapy device that releases
your deepest muscle tension
using a scientifically calibrated
combination of depth
speed and power and now it's as quiet as
ever
as quiet as an electric toothbrush which
makes the experience
even more peaceful and relaxing because
their all-new gen 4 theragon
has this proprietary brushless motor
that keeps it super quiet you're going
to even wonder if it's on
while you soothe your aching muscles
with arrogance signature power amplitude
and effectiveness and right now you can
try theragon risk free for 30 days
there's just no substitute for the
theragun gen4 with an oled screen
personalized theragun app and the quiet
and power you need starting at only one
hundred and ninety nine dollars go to
theragon.com
richroll right now and get your gen4
theragon today
that's theragun.comritrol.theragon.com
rich roll okay back to margaret
so this conversation which i should
point out was recorded remotely
back in early june is about the
intersectionality of the climate crisis
its ties to the pandemic
as well as the protests it's about the
inherent conflict between capitalism
and environmentalism and how we must
decouple
corporate self-interest from the public
good it's about how to deal with
weaponized media
and the way in which we are being
spoon-fed lies by the fossil fuels
industry
but more than anything this is about
effective altruism and the actionable
steps that we can all take now to
backtrack from the global suicide that
we are
precariously nearing i know
it can sound disheartening and at times
it feels like
our personal actions feel futile
our collective bandwidth meanwhile is
maxed out when it comes to
crises and revolutions but embracing the
truth the hard
facts the figures and finding a way to
contribute to positive change is not
only
required of us it really is in many ways
this path to hope to meaning
to inclusion and also very importantly
to empathy margaret's ideologies have
totally reframed how i perceive
address and talk about the climate
crisis and my hope is that her words
will offer you a perspective that is
honest
and that is hopeful but more than
anything
my aspiration is that this conversation
helps to
inspire you to do something
so this is me and dr margaret klein
solomon
margaret welcome to the podcast thank
you for taking the time today
i'm very excited to talk to you thanks
so much for having me
me too so
the first line in your book i think is
is uh quite apropos to what we're
experiencing
right now and it goes like this we are
in a moment of
acute collective suffering and
uh not only is that incredibly true
right now i suspect that
what we're experiencing right now
exceeds anything that you were
contemplating
at the moment that you wrote it and i
have to say just
at the outset here that what i'm dealing
with
in this moment is this sense that
it kind of just feels wrong to talk
about
anything other than human rights civil
rights
black lives matter and social unrest
right now it even feels wrong
to talk about covid and and i guess on
some level
almost indulgent to talk about
the environment at the moment and yet
amidst this you know age of crisis
you know economic government health and
social structures being overwhelmed and
falling apart
beneath all of it is this accelerating
climate
emergency that that we can't forget
so i'm just wondering how you're
thinking about all of this
right now yeah it is certainly
a crisis within a crisis within a crisis
and in some ways
i'm surprised but i i'm
honestly i'm surprised at how quickly
everything is moving
i've known for
six seven years that we
were in an ecological climate and
ecological emergency
that was going to cause the collapse of
civilization
in the short to medium term
you know in the in the coming decades
i've been aware of
that but i didn't yeah i thought it was
a little further
out um the acceleration both in the
climate system
and in the like political system the in
resp
in significant part in response to uh
the climate impacts is it yeah
it has surprised me but i i think i
think that viewing
both coronavirus and the
mass protests in the united states
as part of uh
what paul gilding uh author and
former director of greenpeace calls
uh the great disruption uh that
you know when you live unsustainably
when your system
is unsustainable that means it collapses
it it doesn't go on forever it it it
ends so
it it breaks down so
yeah i think keeping
the climate and ecological factors at
front of mind
when considering every other
emergency is really important
both because it's a critical piece of
ev of every story of everything that's
going on
um and because we can't forget about it
i i mean coronavirus is
here today killing people today the
climate emergency
is is also doing that mainly it's been
in the global south
most people who have starved because of
droughts or uh you know
bangladesh just suffered horrible floods
again so
so it's already taking lives but
it's like coronavirus it's on
exponential growth trajectory uh
acceleration and so
yes there's a ton of crises and they're
all
interrelated but i mean to just stay
grounded
in the reality that our entire economy
our entire society
everything is takes place in
and is fully dependent on our
atmosphere and our the biosphere and
you know the idea that human affairs
however
pressing are separated from that is
i mean it's just never true right
i think that that um what we're seeing
is the limitations of of you know the
human bandwidth to pay attention to
too many things at once you know the
media is very good at centering in on
one specific issue
um and it's acuteness but when we look
at
the climate emergency it's more
difficult to
identify the enemy that we're
marshaling against when we have covid we
see the virus and we can kind of
intuitively understand the things that
need to
be done in order to tackle that and
we've seen
you know the incredible power of the
public to kind of rally around you know
it's like everywhere you go people are
wearing masks for the most part people
are social distancing like they're
adhering to certain
protective protocols in order to deal
with this threat um now we're seeing the
social unrest and everything that's
going on with that and we're seeing you
know a massive
public awakening and awareness to
a societal ill that is in dire need of
redress
the climate right now just feels like
something that is on a low hum
on the back burner i think you know with
this idea like we'll get to that but we
just
you know we don't have the bandwidth at
the moment to really talk about that or
think about that
until we can kind of get over the hump
on these other things and yet
there is this indelible irrefutable
interrelatedness
to the breakdown of all the systems that
we're seeing right now
yes i do think attentional
bandwidth is is a real issue
but i also see a lot
of opportunity
coming from these two
uh emergencies
and and our reaction to them um
with the central thing being
just that normal is over and
i i am very glad about that because
normal was leading us straight
to catastrophe and
you know we this is i i think this is an
opportunity to create a new
normal with for example a green new deal
as the stimulus that puts people
back to work and also
the fact that the public
has experienced an education about
emergency situations about how we can
act
together in order to protect life and
radically alter the economy in order to
protect life
yeah just just at what is possible
for an emergency response suddenly
congress comes up with two trillion
dollars
suddenly everyone can work from home
suddenly people
don't have to fly across the planet like
these
changes are possible and they can happen
very quickly
uh the public's also getting an
education about
exponential risk and
exponential acceleration of
existential risk the fact
that these things happen on a curve and
you have to respond
as soon as possible or else they can get
away from you
um yeah i think that's certainly
a lesson that everybody is taking from
this
and there's definitely this sense of
being
awakened uh from the sleeping self
i guess on some level and so
with that let's take it back a little
bit i mean how you know how did your
awakening occur with respect to your
advocacy around climate i mean i know it
had to do with sandy so if you could
just
like you know tell that story i think it
would be informative so i came to new
york city
in 2009 to pursue uh my clinical
psychology phd
and hurricane irene happened
hurricane sandy happened or superstorm
sandy
and as i was walking around
my neighborhood in the days following
and just seeing all of this destruction
so much
uh damage i there was a
car with a smashed windshield
and someone had put a sign on it that
said
is global warming the culprit and
when i saw that it's like my stomach
dropped
you know i because i i knew and that's
what that's what's so amazing with
uh the climate emergency is
there's so much awareness about
the emergency and so little both
discussion and action so
that sign helped me become actually
aware
of what i already knew if that makes
sense
um so yeah the process of becoming aware
of the emergency
happened through those events as well as
for for many years i was
in denial and especially had
practiced willful ignorance meaning i
knew that this was a scary
situation so i just would avoid it like
sometimes i would read the first few
lines of an article on
climate and then say oh my god i can't
handle this
you know x and but as i
was you know getting older and also
through my own
psychotherapy i was just getting
you know internally stronger and
more able to not do that to actually
look at this so my awareness was kind of
growing but what really changed my life
from which there's like it's a clear
kind of before and after and there's no
going back
is my good friend said to me
i i was planning i was very alarmed and
i was planning to do some
writing i was planning to yeah be kind
of a climate
commentator and author and
my friend said to me don't start a blog
discourse isn't enough think what could
you do
to actually solve this problem
and it was like my brain exploded
because it's like it had i had never
thought about it like that
i was an academic i was a you know yeah
a student
at the idea of i've been a little bit
involved in politics but not really
so the idea of oh actually try to solve
this huge global emergency
it's just too big to think of but
when he threw down that gauntlet i just
realized oh
that's it for me right that's the only
thing that i want
is to as we say at the climate
mobilization
uh cancel the apocalypse right and
i've been on that mission for the past
six years
hmm well what's interesting is that
you've been able to leverage this
specific skill set
that you have you know towards that
solution
and when we kind of canvass the climate
emergency
there's many on-ramps here you could
have been a commentator
a journalist a writer and author on this
subject matter in general
there's political battles that we can
pick there's
technological innovation that can help
solve this problem
but fundamentally if you want to get to
the root of what's
arresting the level or the rate at which
we can
address and overcome these problems it
really does
boil down to our psychological makeup
and how we're thinking about
this issue because that's the true
barrier towards
us actually doing anything about it
you know i come from addiction recovery
and there's a certain architecture in
your steps that remind me of the 12
steps specifically you know acceptance
and breaking these chains of denial that
are so important to solving any personal
problem
but on top of that i'm also like
plant-based i'm part of the vegan
community and i'm very aware of
the various strategies that are deployed
within that subculture to try to
convince other people
that becoming vegan is a good thing to
do
with varying degrees of success and
failure and i think in the venn diagram
there's an overlap that's applicable to
the conversation around
environmentalism because your entry
point and on-ramp is so
relatable it's not that we're not aware
that there's a problem
it's the extent to which we're really
willing to face it and then translate
that increased level of awareness into
some kind of tangible action
that potentially can actually make a
difference
absolutely and i would just add to that
that's i it's awesome that
you're vegan and part
like a leader in that movement
that's obviously extremely important for
animal agriculture and industrial
agriculture is such a huge
contributor to the climate emergency
and just general ecological emergency
and you know there's been such huge
movement towards being plant-based and
all sorts of meat alternatives going
more mainstream i mean so
that that is a really exciting
development and the truth is there's
lots of really exciting developments in
the
climate space bicycling is
resurgent and solar panels are
continually getting more efficient and
cheaper
and new technologies are being created
and so forth and so forth but it's about
scaling it all up at like
by a thousand times something that
only federal governments have
the resources to
do is the kind of system change it's all
there it's all ready
to go we just have lacked the political
will
to implement it and i agree with you but
that is significantly
because of psychological factors and i
think
what the climate emergency movement
is doing is intervening
in that realizing that our enemy
is not just fossil fuel companies
and their huge network and industrial
agriculture but
also denial that denial and passivity
are also enemies and the vested
interests that
you know are doing everything they can
to buttress that level of denial
absolutely i mean i think that
you know the political will to address
and solve these problems at the highest
level
that we see in so many ways is lacking
right now
is also simply a reflection of public
consciousness
and awareness so the way to shift
political will is less
about brow and more about raising
that awareness from a grassroots level
up so in terms of you know advocacy and
the kind of psychological makeup of the
average human being
learning how to crack that code i see as
fundamental to this whole thing but at
the same time
the strategies and the tactics for doing
that
it's like a minefield right like you
didn't
become a climate activist because
somebody browbeat you into it and i
didn't become vegan because somebody
pointed a finger in my face and told me
that i had to i had my own personal kind
of
evolution into it that began with
health and kind of a self-oriented sense
about my own
body that then evolved over time into a
greater sensitivity and awareness about
the larger issues but i had to come to
that
myself and you know had i been
browbeaten at an earlier stage
i might not have made that adjustment
so communication becomes critical
and learning how to effectively
translate a message
in a way that's digestible for people to
hear is important
but also at the same time being mindful
of not
soft pedaling everything like you have
an interesting perspective on
fear and the importance of how fear
plays into this in a positive way
so i'm interested in you know how you
think about the communication
aspect of all of this the first thing we
should recognize
is the amount
of propaganda and misinformation and
lies
that have been propagated incredibly
successfully
by the fossil fuel industry the most
profitable
industry in history we're talking about
billions of dollars
everybody anyone listening to this
podcast has been lied to
very intentionally by this industry
and they're very clever so
it's about yes denial and casting doubt
on the science
which is the same technique that the
tobacco industry used indeed they use
many of the same
scientists and lawyers and everything
doubt is our problem right exactly doubt
is the product and
also that the idea of a
carbon footprint you know that this is
on you
right individuals need to clean up their
own act because
as long as there is a demand for our
product
we have like no choice but to sell it
basically
and then also one of their other lies is
yeah it's a it's a problem and we need
to
you know decarbonize in the long term
and through
gradual policy mechanisms like a carbon
price
and so starting to understand the
different
ways that we have been manipulated and
propagandized
as well as the greater you know american
consumerists
that we've also been sold virtually from
the
time of our birth that you know buying
things is how you
are happy and you know compete get yours
and then buy things is this is like the
american dream
the point of life so first of all
unpacking all of that and realizing
that if we are going to solve this
emergency
it will only be through a political
solution
individual action is fine
i also do some of you know whatever
we have solar panels on our roof and and
whatnot
but it's not politics and we
need a political solution here at
emergency speed and
realizing that gives a lot of guidance
though not obviously it's not doesn't
answer every question but in terms of
where people should direct their energy
which is towards uh building a movement
um because
a social movement i mean honestly i
think about it
sometimes in terms of it's like it plays
a psychological function or a
therapeutic function
it intervenes in denial and says
no we have to pay attention to this so
realizing that raising the alarm
telling the truth and raising the alarm
in the political arena is a
critical part of this uh how we're going
to get out of this
needs to be done i'm sure
from time to time you're confronted with
people who are intelligent or at least
seem intelligent
who are not buying that climate change
is a thing
they'll say the science is exaggerated
we don't really
know there's not adequate science on
this
how do you interface with somebody who's
coming from that place who's seemingly
immune
from having you you know basically
list a bunch of resources and scientists
and
articles etc books that
dispute that point yeah there's two
things i do
um one is i say
uh god i wish that were true because
that's that's really what it is is it's
it's wishful thinking and that's
something we share we
we both want that to be true and i also
say
listen the most profitable industry in
history
has spent billions of dollars to
intentionally lie and
mislead the american public and i'm
sorry to say you've fallen for it
and you know that's it you've been lied
to
well i do want to say with people my age
i'm 34 i hear a lot more
were [ __ ] than uh it's not real
there's a lot
of nihilism and just defeatism
out there yeah that's its own
beast right like how do you catalyze
interest and activism
from somebody who who just perceives
that the ship has sailed and there's
nothing much to be done
there's a sense of powerlessness yeah we
can you know look at electric cars and
ride our bikes but
it seems like such an ineffectual drop
in the bucket
compared to the larger problem and
when the cycle of these environmental
cataclysms seems to be
accelerating from you know the fires
that ravaged australia and the flooding
and
you know everything that that you know
seems to
be happening um at a quicker rate than
we've ever seen
there is a despair that comes over
people where they just feel like
there's nothing that they could
personally do that would be impactful
absolutely and
for a long time
that was somewhat true
i mean i that's of course people can
always
make a difference but until
about two years ago there really wasn't
an active climate emergency movement
in this country or really uh globally i
mean
so my my organization the climate
mobilization
has been demanding a world war ii scale
climate mobilization to eliminate us
emissions in 10 years or less
for the last five years
and for a long time
that was a really fringe position
but with that advent of
extinction rebellion the sunrise
movement and the youth
school strikers and the you know the
green new deal
which which is considerably based on
our work it is possible now
very possible to go and join
a movement that is fighting for
transformation
not reform not gradualism so that's the
good news so so yeah the first thing to
do is just
you know try to give movement education
right
did you know all this stuff that's going
on because
people's nihilism and cynicism which
yeah absolutely does result from a sense
of helplessness
it can change i mean based on internal
factors and also based on political
conditions
like right now the huge
unrest in the united states is
making different political outcomes
very different and and changing people's
calculus
about whether or not to engage in this
movement because
obviously people want to fight winnable
fights
and this is starting to feel more
winnable
yeah and i think what's cool about
not just your organization but your book
i mean your book
is essentially a self-help book it's
about the climate emergency but it's
really about wrapping your head around
the power that we all have to
not just address but actually
participate in this change and you kind
of walk people through these steps
that we can undertake to reframe our
psychological perspective on
how we're thinking about this problem
with actionable steps that we can take
to move the ball forward and i like like
i said earlier
it starts with acceptance like coming to
this
understanding and having to break the
denial you know welcoming the emotions
that
flood in with that i mean you kind of
talk about tara brock and
her you know rubric for how to think
about this
then reimagining the story you know
entering this emergency mode and then
joining the movement
and i think you know when you kind of
walk through that
you start to realize that we are more
powerful
than we think that we are and when we
turn on the news and we see
all of the social activity in all its
forms right now i think that there is an
empowerment
lesson in there for all of us that we
can
provoke the change that we want to see
in the world and that there
is quite a bit of hope to be mined from
what we're seeing at the moment yeah i i
think
when you view the climate emergency
from the perspective of psychology and
social psychology
and allow that to inform your
understanding of what
the social movement needs to accomplish
it is okay we are
living in a lie
that things are normal and that there's
not a climate emergency and
again that's why the coronavirus
and mass protests are
you know i'm i'm glad not to
be fully in that delusion anymore but
we're still
in the mass delusion that um we don't
face a near-term
existential threat not other people
you and me and my family and your family
and the whole human family
is in danger because of the climate
emergency
that understanding we're in mass
collective denial like
vaclav havel pointed out in
the soviet union in czechoslovakia
that there was mass understanding
that the state was corrupt
just like there's there is mass
understanding in the united states
that this is an existential threat but
by
just living within the system living as
if things were normal rather than
talking about it and raising the alarm
and changing your life
in response to this we're perpetuating
this sense of normalcy and so what's so
important about
this recognition and again that vaclav
havel
used to create the velvet revolution
and peacefully democratize
the czech republic is through if you're
in this
situation where there is
something that is true and
is largely understood as true
and yet there is not
action attached to that yet
that there is an understanding that that
that is a bubble
that can be punctured right that is a
situation that can
flip really quickly once we start
a collective awakening and it is
starting it just needs to
massively expand right a little more
inflation absolutely
to get it to get it to that point um
like so many
problems it seems that
part of you know what's preventing
an acceleration of the solution is this
misalignment
of incentives you know as individuals
we're all kind of programmed to go out
and get what's ours
to you know satisfy our material urges
and with lobbying efforts who are
invested in the status quo and kind of
diluting the public
is there a way in which
capitalism and environmentalism
on the level that you're talking about
can co-exist or how do we
decouple corporate self-interest from
the public good it seems that we need to
find a way to realign these incentives
so that
systems kind of auto direct towards
solutions rather than exacerbating the
problem
so absolutely we need to
realign incentives i i definitely agree
with that
however we are just
so advanced in the
climate emergency like we're not heading
off a cliff
we are off the cliff and we need to
hit reverse not the brakes
so i think that
in order to move as quickly as humanly
possible
it involves enlisting
business as well as labor
and the whole society into
an effort but what changes
what absolutely needs to change
is that basic orientation
and and let's say power arrangements
that
at the moment there is an understanding
that
you know it's like the neoliberal uh
assumptions that the
government can't uh successfully
intervene in the market in order to
deal with issues or pass strong
legislation
command and control legislation rather
than just incentive based
legislation right like we don't have to
charge 10 cents for single-use plastic
or whatever we could just
ban it like that is a policy instrument
that we've kind of forgotten how to use
but during world war ii fdr said
no more consumer cars are going to be
sold in this country because we need
all of this capacity to make tanks
planes
and ships and so they're still
participating
but the government's in the driver's
seat so that's
the kind of emergency mobilization
element
in which very planned and emergency
speed
transition of the economy happens and
that's just the
overriding top priority so which yeah it
just needs a lot of active
intervention so then what comes after
that
i don't worry about too much for me
getting to
you know beyond zero emissions to
negative emissions and stopping this
six mass extinction of species that's
like enough for me
but absolutely a society that doesn't
have financial incentives
that lead us to legislative governmental
structure that leads us to
destruction i mean it's like no one
no one can say this system is working
you know if they live in the reality of
yeah physics
this reality in the third dimension
right you know you mentioned
fdr that made me think of your bystander
effect
example you use this analogy of the fire
alarm going off in the office
and the extent to which people respond
to that
is cued by the urgency level of the boss
the person at the top
and when you speak about fdr we're
talking about a strong leader who had a
vision
you know about a certain solution we're
lacking that at the moment like how
important
is it that at the very top we have
somebody
who takes this seriously so that we can
all kind of you know fall
in step with this bystander effect we
can raise the
consciousness level from the ground up
but on some level
there's something to be said for
leadership that takes this seriously oh
absolutely
i i mean you know the climate
mobilization endorsed bernie sanders who
is
proposing a 16 trillion dollar world war
ii scale climate mobilization
so i mean we yeah we thought he was the
the leader that we need um
i mean trump is utterly incompetent i
mean we don't we don't
waste our breath trying to advocate for
trump to do this we would
try to convince biden administration
to take this on but yeah i mean
okay so yeah alexandria ocasio-cortez
i think provides inspirational
leadership for the climate emergency
movement
right she certainly filled that vacuum
she did some but
while it is absolutely true that we need
leadership from the top it is also true
that if you're in a burning office
building you don't have to be the boss
to yell and tell everybody to
get out and take the fire drill
seriously
so the
mission that i am inviting
readers to take on
is really about
becoming a leader i mean joining this
movement
and bringing in others through
spreading the word and i mean yeah
recruiting
yeah to just try and increase their
power and influence as much as possible
in order to
spread this message and save humanity
so it is both true that we need
leadership at the top and true that each
of us
have to you know summon
all of our strengths and courage
in order to offer
whatever leadership we can in our
families and workplaces
and communities mm-hmm how do you think
about
greenwashing like there there seems to
be a lot of
uh you know kind of commercial co-opting
of people's interest
in in environmentalism
uh to the extent that you know products
are developed and pitched and
presented to the marketplace that appear
to be
solution oriented and yet in fact are
not
and that kind of lulls people into a
placated state that they're actually
doing something or that they're active
when in truth it ultimately ends up
making the solution more difficult
preventing activism because
people feel like they're already playing
their part so do you think about that
issue at all yeah so
i i don't
believe that it's very effective anyway
any kind of activism that is based on
something you buy
i think that that really reinforces the
idea
of americans as consumers
and whereas i i really i mean
i really want to emphasize the fact that
we are citizens and that we
make the government and it is
it's up to us to create a system
that cancels the apocalypse and protects
humanity and all
all life and that no one is going to do
that
for us again maybe bernie sanders could
have
taken care of it but even then we would
have need a robust
movement making sure that he does so
to have the assumption that no one is
coming to save us
so you know we're gonna create
the leader that we need you know the the
saying
the feminist saying uh be
the man you always wanted to marry
it's like be the leader
that you crave to see at the national
level like
just just try to find that within
yourself and bring that
into your endeavors yeah i like that no
one's coming to save
us you've got to take that mantle on for
yourself
back to this world war ii kind of
manhattan project
um approach to solving the problem like
walk me through
the ideal version of you know what that
looks like from your perspective like
what are the biggest problems
that we need to tackle how are we going
to you know
deconstruct and reimagine those systems
whether they're agriculture
or energy etc like what does that
specifically look like great so you can
imagine that we have gotten this
question a lot
for for years and so my co-founder of
the organization ezra silk
wrote a 100-page victory plan
that spells this out for any listeners
that want to take
the deep dive but i'll i'll give some
top lines and and it just goes to show
also how incredibly complex this is
because even
the victory plan the 100 pages it's
still a high level
overview so so anyway what do we need to
do
we need to transform our
energy agricultural and industrial
systems of our economy as if well yeah
and i mean
it'll have implications obviously for
the financial sector and other
sectors but at emergency speed so how do
you do that
um oh and yeah sorry our transportation
sector i mean it's just on and on and on
it's everything
so yeah how do you do that you
immediately
ban all new fossil fuel
infrastructure and development
so no new export terminals for gas
no new coal plants no new pipelines
no new anything and this is obvious but
it's
still somehow radical okay so we shut
all that down
and then we create a 10-year timeline to
shut down
the existing fossil fuel capacity
in the united states so the plants
and then you create a
massive program to ramp up renewables
and energy conservation in order to
replace
the fossil fuel that's getting phased
out so quickly so
that's going to take a lot of jobs
to put solar or green roofs on every
roof
and insulate every home you know
winterize every
home and to create
just a renewable energy production
miracle we want to convert
factories into solar and wind
producing factories so that's a little
bit on the energy side
on the transportation side to
immediately make
zero miles per gallon the new mileage
per gallon
standard so all new vehicles must be
electric and then to work on getting
fossil fuel vehicles off the road
through a cash for clunkers program
in some cases retrofits are possible
cars with an internal combustion engine
can
be electrified and move towards public
transportation
obviously we need to build out a huge
high-speed rail
network we need to so and
and drastically curtail flying
we need to ban factory farms
and transition all agriculture
to regenerative practices through
a combination of you know banning
pesticides phasing out pesticides as
well as
you know education and providing support
for farmers to do that
i mean so yeah we need huge research
grants we need to create a super smart
grid
we need bike lanes i mean it's it's huge
the amount of stuff we need to do
and the only possible way we would do it
is if we realized
that we have no choice because if we
don't do this we will
literally all die in chaos
yeah and getting people to understand
the level of that existential
threat seems to be not only is you know
that's not only like the most important
piece like that's really the focus of
your
expertise right getting them you know to
this level of of acceptance and then
activated and self-directed
uh you know and on the right path um
how does your you know kind of
solution-oriented perspective on this
square with
um the work that paul hawkin is doing
with drawdown
do those things line up or is there a
you know kind of a difference of
perspective there see somebody i've had
on the podcast who you know spoke about
his various
channels for addressing this on a global
level because a lot of what you're
talking about also is
it's about you know kind of the united
states and what we can do but as we know
like this crisis doesn't respect
national borders if we're doing this but
china isn't like how are you thinking
about all of that
so drawdown is awesome
and it lays out areas
like refrigerants and educating women
and girls
and that for example that
can reduce carbon emissions
and so as i said
earlier in terms of solutions we've got
them
and they do such a good job of
demonstrating this and it's really
just about achieving scale i do
think we have some differences in terms
of
theory of change of how that happens and
what kind of
policy should be sought with myself and
the climate mobilization
coming in for incredibly strong
legislation
massive spending in order to get all
this done it's gonna it's gonna be super
expensive
and just you know kind of doing whatever
it takes at a legislative level an
emergency mobilization i think paul
hawkin has a vision that's
involves businesses and other sectors
kind of taking action on their own
yeah um yeah not not
through necessarily command and control
and
yeah the kind of emergency mobilization
type approach
when we when we think about you know the
psychological
aspect of this you know my sense is that
everybody thinks they're look everybody
you know thinks that they're a good
person
you know that they're doing the best
that they can and
when confronted with certain
aspects of this movement it's not
uncommon for
people to be defensive or
self-protective
so when i experience that myself
i'm reflective of my own kind of
inherent biases
and i think you know what am i being
defensive about
is there some underlying you know thing
that i need to look at in my own
behavior and i think beneath that
is perhaps some unconscious
shame or my attempt to protect my own
self-esteem because i feel like my
identity is being threatened
can can you give me an example of the
kind of situation that you're talking
about what might make you feel this way
oh i mean it could be as banal as my
wife saying you know
why didn't you take the garbage out last
night you know it can be anything like
i'm a sensitive person you know i will
get defensive and protective and then
i'll react
rather than you know take a moment to
pause and respond
mindfully to what is actually being
said to me so i'm just thinking about
like if i'm called out on some
character defect of mine or some
behavior
my natural inclination is to
be defensive and i think that's a
natural thing and i've done a lot
of work over the years to not behave in
that way
but as we all know we all have our
buttons and when they get pushed
we're going to you know basically play
whatever
loop is programmed into our psyche yeah
but
and by being aware of them and mindful
of them
is the best that we can do towards
growth so it's that's great
right so so in terms of of kind of
creating an architecture around
around communication on these subjects
like you're
you're out there you're trying to get
people excited about this movement
you're trying to
empower them but we all have people who
are
who are kind of resistant out there so
knowing what what you know about you
know the human brain and
and human behavior i think it would be
instructive and helpful to kind of
provide some guideposts to people
who want to learn how to be better
communicators about this
or how to think about their own
participation
in this movement for themselves for
their own personal self-actualization
yeah it's such an important point what
you what you bring up
about people's self-esteem and how
if someone feels criticized that is not
their most when they're most receptive
to what you have to say
and it can be hard because when we talk
about the
climate emergency i mean it's such bad
news
it's such challenging painful
awkward news so
i do think it's really important for
people to really think about how they
engage and how they communicate and
always try to be
improving on that so i really appreciate
the question um
i think that one of the most important
things is
to speak from the heart with climate
we have gotten so far down the road of
science that you know people read about
climate in the science section
and they look to scientists to tell them
what's going on
and what we should do and it's like this
is not a science issue this is an
everything issue
and scientists play an important role
but you know we can talk about this from
a
perspective of our values and our
emotions
and our futures so yeah i would
probably recommend against a kind of
let's say powerpoint type science driven
approach plus
people don't uh generally feel
comfortable
doing that so i invite people to
have personal conversations about the
climate emergency
with your friends and family in which
you talk about your reaction
how are you feeling about what's going
on and
obviously this includes covid and the
mass protests against police brutality
and racism
that we're seeing to talk about how
you're feeling
what you think the future holds and your
fears about the future and how you're
processing this and ask them the same
and how are you feeling about it and
what are your thoughts about the future
and how are you processing it
and you don't have to have all the
answers
you don't have to have everything worked
out it's
just to connect on the level of
like holy [ __ ] have you seen the most
recent
updates about what's happening in the
climate do you know what's happening in
the climate it is accelerating so
quickly i'm so scared
that is so impactful to share what's in
your heart i'm really you know if
to say i'm i'm really thinking about not
having children
given what i'm seeing and think the
future holds
i mean a huge amount of people are
experiencing painful feelings
consciously related to the climate
emergency yeah
56 of americans say we're in a climate
emergency
and 80 of young people think that
global warming is a major threat
to life as we know it but yet there's
still
very little personal conversation
going on so that's yeah that's
definitely the number one thing
i would say yeah it's interesting i mean
it's certainly an issue
that should not be political that should
have
bipartisan support and yet like so many
you know big issues that we're
contending with right now have become
politicized tremendously politicized
you know this trend that really kind of
entered the public consciousness around
the 2016
election has only accelerated the
tribalism
the weaponization of social media the
fake news
and the increasing extent to which we
are siloed in our chosen
media information diets of choice
and when you're talking about you know
trying to confront this
issue you're inevitably going to butt up
against
people who are getting their information
from a very different source and have
become very calcified
around any idea that contravenes
what they've acclimated themselves to
which
just is this extraordinary
complexifier to this whole thing like
how to untangle
that knot when everything is political
now
and we're so self-identified with
whatever
tribe you know it is that we choose to
belong to
yeah absolutely this is a huge
central problem in our politics
generally speaking and on the climate in
particular
one thing i would say is don't worry
about the deniers or don't focus on them
they're going to be the last people to
join
this movement but even
they perhaps can get there but it's not
going to happen now
so don't waste your time spend your time
talking to people
who do understand what's going on with
the climate
but are still going on with their lives
as
usual move them to greater action
like people say oh but that's preaching
to the choir
or something and it's it's like no
that's getting the choir together
our choir has not been doing a very good
job recently and we need to
really grow it and its power so
yeah you don't i yeah i wouldn't i
wouldn't waste time honestly talking to
climate deniers you could tell them if
you're interested
you know if you are reconsidering or if
you're interested or whatever
we could talk but there's so much
low-hanging fruit like the 80 of young
voters who think that global warming is
a
threat to life as we know it like
organizing them bringing them into the
movement
it's easy all you need to do is show
them how yeah
and get you know and encourage them to
do it so there's so much to do there
i would say that's where it's at yeah i
mean that's the low hanging fruit and
the easy sell and the on-ramps
it's just building the appropriate
on-ramp to activate those people in the
most effective way
yeah um you know another thing that's
somewhat unique about this problem
is and you point this out in the book
is that we are together collectively
all victims of the climate emergency
but through passivity we're also it's
perpetrators and from a psychological
perspective
that's confusing right we're suffering
as a result of this but we're also
active participants in its acceleration
and untangling that knot
seems to be kind of a psychological
minefield as well
right and this gets into or back to what
you were saying
about self-esteem
and that guilt
to be a part of this problem is one
thing
that holds us back from
fully engaging with it and doing what we
can to stop it because we've been
told that it's our fault
and i like to say it's not your fault
but it is your responsibility
you know no one has to be born into this
terribly destructive and broken system
we're here
at this time and this is the reality
that we're faced with and i don't see
what someone could do with their
time on this planet that would be more
meaningful or noble
than to fight for humanity in the living
world
take that on as your personal mission
and just decide that this is not gonna
happen
on your watch right
and once you've an individual has kind
of faced that
truth and and grappled with the you know
the fear and the grief and all these
other emotions that come up with
breaking that chain of denial about
what's actually going on you have this
third step
which is entitled reimagining your life
story so
walk me through what that means so
in the step before welcome your fear
grief and other painful feelings i
encourage readers to grieve
not only the people and nature
animals that have already been lost but
also to grieve the future that
they thought they had their hopes and
plans
realizing that it's it's just not going
to unfold
the way you hoped and planned and
instead there's this other reality
of that's going to be you know
accelerating
chaos once you do that and i i did
realizing that you know being a
psychologist and writing books and
having a family
which is what i had planned and it
seemed like a great plan
but when i realized that it wasn't gonna
work
if civilization was just collapsing all
around me
i no longer saw satisfaction down that
road
and what that does is open up
space for a new
identity a new future a new trajectory
and a new
story of self so
i invite people to ask what if this is
why i'm here
and what if everything in my life had
been leading up to this
all my challenges all my skills and
talents like what if this is really what
it's all about
and imagine what it could be to have
that heroic mission to take that on
so yeah it's a
it's a it's a tall order you know it's
it's hard but i just think it's
so worth it yeah it's very much
in the ilk of the joseph campbell heroes
journey
and there's this trajectory from
self-interest to
being kind of community oriented right
like the self-esteem
that comes with devoting yourself to
something that's bigger than you
and more important than you know your
own personal
concerns that i think girds people's
lives
with meaning and to the extent that they
can identify
with this movement or perhaps an aspect
of it maybe it's
animal agriculture maybe it's solar
energy
you know like sometimes i feel like well
global climate change so it's so vast
and all-consuming
like is there wisdom in identifying one
aspect of it that
speaks to you personally that you feel
like you have an emotional connection to
and can do the best good like how do you
think about
parsing this into various sectors where
you can
channel people's energy in a direction
that feels like a fit for them
definitely people need to find their
place
in this movement and
i absolutely some people
are you know drawn to regenerative
agriculture and
others to trains and you know every
and and that's great and you know people
should follow their
heart in those ways but
make sure to make it or to also be
political because if you're just having
a regenerative farm
for example that's great it's certainly
much better than having a conventional
farm
but i i just don't think that's
gonna change the world yeah you're
thinking in terms of scale like
whatever you choose like it has to have
a lever
that can move things beyond you know the
immediate
like thing that you're involved in right
but and maybe that's i have a
regenerative farm
and i bring people from my community
there
to educate them about the climate
emergency and
regenerative agriculture and i share my
insights with other regenerative farmers
you know there's ways to
make a lot of different things a part
of this movement it just has to be you
know
consciously part of what you're doing
yeah i i guess what
i'm thinking of you know i'm just
analogizing it in my mind to
the vegan movement and and understanding
that
you know certain people are very good at
being
you know brazen with their messaging and
unapologetic and kind of
you know edgy and other people are more
effective
at provoking change in more subtle ways
just because of their
natural disposition and i think you need
all different types in you know every
shape and form
but finding the vein that you know you
can tap that fits you
is you know what i'm always thinking
about in terms of how i
direct people and think about my own
messaging but i do think that piece of
figuring out how that's going to be
effective in a broader sense is
the important part of the calculus that
you know perhaps i've overlooked or
should think more deeply about
yeah choosing your place in the climate
movement
and it's and it's also it's not just
like one and done
it's a it's an evolving thing you should
always be reaching for you know how is
this going and
how can i have a greater impact that's
just an
ongoing process but choosing it is
as complex and personal
as choosing a career right there's just
so many different factors right and
so that's why the final step
step five i try to say okay well this is
what the movement needs
these different categories of things and
you know
think about how you fit into them
so just like for some concrete examples
movements need bookkeepers and graphic
designers
and people to help with child care and
people to make
you know meals for events whatever
catering
people to do tech support people to
offer
child care at meetings translators
there's so many different things as well
as of course they always need
organizers and fundraisers
if you want if you want to be welcome in
any social movement organization tell
them you're
willing to raise funds so there's i mean
there's just so many different
ways to do this and yeah i mean
and you know on the on the high end and
i always encourage people to go
all the way i mean run for office
start an initiative get your business or
organization to declare a climate
emergency
and to reckon with their role in this
movement
there's so much that is helpful
to the listener you know there's
something you can do
there's something for you in this
movement right yeah yeah
of course one of the questions that you
ask in the book
is you know how we got to this place why
are we
passively accepting collective suicide
and
you know underneath that kind of
underscoring this thing is this
idea that it's because in so many ways
our society treats life as if it were
a cheap commodity like that's a line out
of your book
to overcome that
it seems to me to require a shift in our
in our value system
right and when i read that it's a
provocative line i immediately think of
all the things that i do that are that
are not perfect you know i'm
talking to you through a microphone and
a computer that's full of all kinds of
minerals that i don't know where they
came from and i'm certain that
you know they weren't mined in a way
that was protective of the environment
like we are all
complicit on some level in participating
in a system that is creating the undoing
of the planet
and that dissonance becomes very like i
want to think that like
my value system states that
i don't treat life as if it were a cheap
commodity and yet i'm you know it goes
back to what i was saying before like
this
idea that we're both victim and
perpetrator here but
in order to truly like shift this
value perspective away from treating
life as if it were a cheap commodity and
towards valuing it
more seems to be you know that's a
that's a big
thing right like we can all get involved
in causes we can participate
but are you optimistic that we can
arrive at that place where i mean that
it would seem like there would need to
be
total system upheaval of governments and
you know political systems to arrive at
that place
because at present we value life so
poorly
um i guess i'm not like that's not
really a question it was more like an
observation i suppose
yeah yeah i mean that you know i just
thought of that in that moment right i
guess what i'm saying
above anything else is it's just a
recognition of the complexity
and the difficulty like the the
difficulty factor of what we're trying
to accomplish here what you're trying to
accomplish here is extreme
yes um and i take great comfort in in
your optimism around it and the activism
that you've you know shouldered for
yourself and your organization
and i am hopeful and i'm surrounded by
young people who are
extremely you know activated by
this cause and you know i want to
believe that we're going to be able to
tackle and overcome this
and i have to juxtapose that against
some level of admitted
despair that i see when you know i
you know scroll through today's news
cycle and i see the violence and i see
the
you know level of hatred being
perpetrated and on some level like
there's a
this process has to occur for us to get
to the other side and
and transcend these age-old problems
that we have
but in my own mind the attempt to kind
of
reconcile all of this you know leaves me
at times like
less hopeful or confused
so one element that i
really want to emphasize is
thinking about our system
and our role within that
because we participate
in this system there is not
really a way out i mean you could be
like a
renunciant you know like a monk or
something
but it's you have to take really extreme
measures
in order to not participate in the
basic global economy and
energy system and you know all of it
and i certainly don't think we should
shame people for that
but i actually don't think i mean yeah
okay so by living in the system
by consuming there is some level of
guilt and responsibility
but i think about passivity and
lack of political engagement as
the larger like that to me is where
the responsibility lies and i think it
was naomi oreskes
who said that the abolitionists
in this country knew that
their clothes were made by slaves
and that the cotton was picked by slaves
and that this was a slave process
but they knew they had to change the
system
not their clothes and i just i mean i
feel like looking back
you can see it seems obvious
right that a movement to ask people to
change their consumption patterns and
try to buy
clothes that were made only by
free workers it would not have been
as effective as fighting the institution
head-on
on the field of politics and public
opinion
[Music]
one of the things well the the sort of
you know step five
final chapter in your book is about like
how to actually
you know join the movement and be
effective in my experience there's a lot
of people who are energized by this
movement but they're not quite sure
where to direct that energy
you know you can go to the climate
mobilization project
website or you can go to an extinction
rebellion um
rally etc but i think you know it's
important to try to provide people with
some guidance about
how to direct that in the most effective
way so talk a little bit about
you know somebody who's listening to
this or read your book
and they're excited and they're ready to
go like how do you then
channel that in the right direction like
what can somebody who's just living in
the suburbs somewhere
begin to do great so the first thing is
to find out what's
happening in your area even i mean in
this
moment even that is going to be virtual
but
it's good to just find out what groups
are operating
as well as to start to understand the
landscape
i encourage people to look for
some criteria in what groups they're
going to join
do you call it an emergency language
matters this is a climate emergency this
is not
a little change um even more important
do they advocate transformational change
not reform okay so an example of
reform is carbon pricing and
many in many sectors of the
environmental movement carbon pricing is
considered the
gold standard of what we need to do
but it's too late carbon pricing perhaps
can play a role
in a larger mobilization but it is not
worth it to campaign for carbon pricing
alone
so look for a group that is talking
about
10 years to zero emissions and emergency
response and emergency mobilization
and that's growing right so
extinction rebellion the sunrise
movement the school strikers
the climate mobilization and many local
organizations
as well you know have taken on this
platform
so find out what's going on with those
organizations and what
the advocacy platforms are of
the other organizations available is a
great first step thinking about your own
skills and
resources and networks and doing an
inventory of that
so i mean obviously i i would love to
recommend that people
read the book and that chapter facing
the climate emergency
how to transform yourself with climate
truth because
it's a really i mean it's quite involved
you got to think about how much
time you have and if you're willing to
donate money
and you know yeah what skills you have
what you're willing to do what you're
not willing to do are you willing to get
arrested
so to really take seriously that kind of
self-assessment
and bringing that together with an
understanding of
what the movement needs and what's going
on in your local area
is what i would say as well as the
addendum to that is
and and this is to everybody
talk about the climate emergency
as much as possible and do it
personally yeah on the subject of
philanthropy um and from kind of an
effective altruism perspective
if somebody wants to donate money who
are the best recipients of that that are
provoking the greatest amount of change
i mean there's so many
places to donate now it's hard to know
you know who's doing the great work and
where those funds can be used most
effectively for the most amount of
change
yes so i would strongly recommend
funding newer smaller
organizations and i really recommend
not funding the big green
organizations such as nrdc
sierra club greenpeace does some good
work i guess i guess maybe they're okay
but there's a nature conservancy
these organizations are
not on top of how bad
this emergency is league of conservation
voters they are in denial
they are in the gradualist paradigm and
that is significantly because they've
gotten too
cozy with power they value being
insiders
more you know and they don't want to do
any kind of agitation
so give to the organizations i
mentioned previously extinction
rebellion sunrise movement
climate mobilization school strikers and
that's
you know the future coalition is one of
the key school strike organizations
um and so yeah look at look at their
demands
again we are out of time for weak
demands if someone is promoting
the decarbonization by 2050 it's just
i mean come on we don't have 30 years
and
it's certainly not worth funding an
environmental group
that is advocating such a
like weak and not reality based message
so yeah i think that
kind of targeted giving i i mean this
new movement this climate emergency
movement
that has emerged it is a tiny fraction
of the resources that the big green
has and it has made a much more
significant impact
through its passion and willingness to
tell the truth
so i would strongly direct people
towards
climate emergency organizations that are
operating in the political and social
sphere it's a tiny fraction
of climate funding goes to that it's
like a new area so another
another group to mention is the climate
emergency fund
which sprouted to fund groups like this
and new groups right that have no track
record but that want to get started
and you know the climate emergency fund
will give them small grants like 500
bucks
to you know host their first protest or
whatnot so that they're pretty cool they
take risks that other funds don't so if
you don't feel comfortable giving
directly to an organization
that's a good approach they know how to
disperse it yeah i would the last thing
i would say is up to apply these same
standards to political
candidates that you donate to obviously
donations matter a lot in u.s politics
so
letting a candidate know that you're
only supporting candidates that call it
a climate emergency that advocate for an
emergency response 10 years to zero
emissions
whatever that's i mean that's like one
of the most effective ways to influence
a candidate
so other than aoc who else
on the hill is is really you know
pushing this message
earl blumenour and
aoc introduced the climate emergency
declaration
in that house bernie sanders introduced
it in the senate
so yeah that's that's
some people to flag ed markey
who's getting primaried from
the you know centrist democrat joe
kennedy has been a
climate champion there's not a huge
amount
of people that are doing
nearly enough i wish the list was longer
you and me both well let's um
i want to give you an opportunity before
we close here to talk a little bit more
about the climate mobilization project
and perhaps kind of what your immediate
focus is
right now and some of the work that
you're doing so the
climate mobilization's key organizing
activity is our climate emergency
campaign
which has helped achieve
more than 1500
of climate emergency primarily from
local governments but also from
national governments and even the eu
though
unfortunately some of those governments
attached to 2050 decarbonization
timeline
totally contradicting themselves in
their declaration
and it's quite a cognitive pretzel
but anyway in other cases it works
really well to help
shift the terms of the debate so for
example
ann arbor michigan declared a climate
emergency
and unveiled a billion dollar climate
plan that would get
them to net zero emissions by 2030 which
is quite ambitious for a city of that
size
20 cities in california and
massachusetts
have now after declaring a climate
emergency
banned the natural gas hookups in new
construction
making all new construction electric
appliances
electric heating so we work with local
organizations and organizers who want to
enlist their local governments as
allies in the fight with declaring a
climate emergency
as the start of a campaign that's great
i also i also
want to say i am working on a project
around the book and around creating
models for facilitated discussions
around
these issues in which people can share
feelings
and process together and so i'm also
personally really leaning into the
psychological
side and looking to operationalize that
as much as possible
oh that's cool i like that idea so in
other words getting like smaller groups
of people together to just
process and talk about you know how
they're thinking about it or yeah
what does that mean yeah exactly i mean
right now
there's two kinds of discussions that we
do one is called pain into action
and that's for people who haven't read
facing the climate emergency
and in at first everyone shares what
they're feeling
about the climate emergency and then in
the second round
people share ideas about action
for themselves what they might do and
it's a bit of brainstorming i mean it's
very basic i mean it's not rocket
science but people say to me all the
time
no one ever asked me how i feel
about the climate emergency and it's
like
huh maybe we should be talking about
this
and then we're also putting together a
format for people who
have read the book so it's a yeah kind
of like a
i don't know a politically engaged book
club kind of
a politically and psychologically
engaged book
kind of approach right well cool
i mean i love i love that idea i love
the book
i should say that it's a very easy read
i mean there's this sense that you think
you're going to get into
something that's you know super heavy
about the science behind
the climate emergency and it's really
less about that and much more
about you know how to think about it
like we've been talking about
psychologically and how to you know
channel
that into action i think he did a great
job it's very easily digestible and i
should also point out
what's very cool about this that i love
is that your publisher
is not only a b core but they're like
carbon neutral and the book is
printed on recycled paper and they have
this like environmental benefits
statement on the back page and
everything so
you are walking your talk with that's
cool let me let me also mention that all
proceeds
from book sales on our side go to
climate mobilization project cool of
course um
excellent so uh if people are
digging on margaret's message definitely
pick up the book facing the climate
emergency
go to climate mobilization project the
website
and any other place that you want to
direct people so
i'm sorry you said the
climatemobilization.org and
facingtheclimateemergency.com
oh go to all of them one is one is for
the book one is for the organization
both great sites and you can be followed
on twitter
at climate psych correct yeah cool
all right i think we did it how do you
feel uh i
think that went really well i think so
too
i think people are gonna really enjoy it
so i appreciate you sharing your message
is powerful um
with everybody today and if there's
anything i can ever do to
help with your work and your cause
please reach out to me i really enjoy it
well
this is an incredible help to
appear like this so i really appreciate
it cool peace
plants namaste
so that happened we did that did it bend
your noodle
margaret's an incredible communicator i
think i hope you guys are feeling
more inspired than despondent because
we need you this crisis is important we
can do this but we got to do it together
if you're feeling at all altruistic you
can find the aforementioned climate
groups in today's episodes show notes i
also encourage you to check out
margaret's book
please read this book facing the climate
emergency
it will not disappoint you can find
margaret on twitter at climate psych
and on instagram just go to climate
mobilization
we also have another roll-on ama coming
up in the forth coming weeks
you can leave us a voicemail with your
question at 424-235-4626
and you can also leave a message on our
facebook group
if you'd like to support the work we do
here on the show subscribe rate and
comment on it on apple podcasts
on spotify on youtube share the show or
your favorite episodes with friends or
on social media
and you can support us on patreon at
richworld.com forward slash donate
i appreciate my team who works very hard
week and week out to put on the show
jason camiolo for audio engineering
production
show notes and interstitial music blake
curtis and margot lubin who typically
video the show but today is audio only
jessica miranda for graphics
ally rogers who takes portraits when we
do in-person podcasts dk for advertiser
relationships
and theme music by tyler pie trapper pie
and hari mathis
thanks for the love you guys see you
back here soon with another amazing
episode until then
peace plants namaste you got this
let's act together come on let's do it
[Music]
so
[Music]
you